[Musique]
fin des années 60 dans un petit village
français mais pas n'importe lequel
sûrement le plus célèbre dans le monde
Saint-Tropez deux artistes se
rencontrent et vont faire l'histoire on
peut dire à l'image de la vague hippie
ensemble vivre une histoire d'amour mais
qui va très vite devenir très artistique
on a vu projeté de manière tout à fait
privée avec la mairie de Saint-Tropez et
l'office du tourisme de Saint-Tropez le
film pour que les partenaires et aussi
l'équipe puisque le découvrir en
avant-première mais là cette fois-ci
c'est vraiment la première française du
film ce mercredi 7 juin au Champeau rue
des Écoles et ça va être je crois
l'aboutissement de de beaucoup de choses
mais surtout ça va être je pense je
pense beaucoup au public en fait qui va
enfin pouvoir découvrir ce film mais et
je crois que ça va être le début de
beaucoup de belles rencontres
alors pour l'instant c'est vraiment de
de profiter de mercredi avec le public
pour la première et après prévoir
d'autres dates notamment on commence à
regarder pour les dates pour Lyon mais
aussi bien sûr la distribution en France
plus large et à l'international pour que
l'âge d'or soit accessible au plus grand
nombre on travaille avec un distributeur
américain sur ce sujet et ce sera
formidable après la première avec la
France de pouvoir voir ce film voyager
plus
[Musique]